well the primary duties a music director
of the Academy Award show have to do
with the selection of music or the
various awards but more importantly
dealing with well the various performers
of the songs who are all very important
people and the music director wants to
see of course but they are comfortable
that they have the kind of arrangements
that they would like to have and that
life isn't generally a comfortable
affair
the songs nominated this year are a
raindrops falling on my head from Butch
Cassidy and the Sundance Kid
what are you doing the rest of your life
from happy ending true grit from true
grit come Saturday morning from the
sterile cuckoo and gene from the prime
of Miss Jean Brodie now this year every
one of these songs is going to receive
some form of production either by use of
a live dancers on the spot or a very
interesting use of film the question of
how we get to the music quickly is an
interesting one actually the answer is
that we don't get to the music as
quickly as most people think we do if
you really listen very hard you will see
that after the winner is announced
there's a burst of applause and if you
count about a 1 or 2 you will see that
it takes that long for the music to
sound the way it's done is that the 5
pieces of music each representing one
nominee are in a single sheet of music
and of course the members of the
orchestra are very interested in what
the outcome of the award is and they
themselves are listening they spot that
piece of music and by the time the baton
comes down on a downbeat they're there
well as a matter of fact that's exactly
what happened 2 years ago when I first
conducted the show I had my hand in the
air ready to give the downbeat but
something I thought was going to be
something other than what I was
nominated for and they announced my name
I must tell you that I never dropped a
baton so quickly and I got up on the
stage somehow I don't remember quite how
now that relates to this year in a very
odd way this year
I am once again nominated for the song
True Grit and I'm also conducting the
show and this year we're in a pit of a
deep water pit at the Music Centre and
they asked me what would happen if I
should win as the arrangements are a
little more difficult and my answer is
that if that happens I'll find some way
to get up on the stage you don't have to
apply